I want to talk about something that's a
little controversial do you mind added
sure I love controversy all right
there's a growing controversy in this
country because some politicians have
started saying Americans should not be
allowed to vote unless they can pass the
same naturalization test that immigrants
need to pass in order to become citizens
they think that's the only way to be
fair mm-hmm now I'm gonna go out on a
limb here and say I think it's a great
idea I really do I think it's a good
idea for all of us to have to have some
basic knowledge of this country in order
to know the rules of the road to get a
driver's license exactly thanks pal and
to prove it to prove that I'm serious
about this once again I'm going to do
something that no other talk show host
dares to do I'm gonna take the US
citizenship test right now here on
television I just want to make sure you
know what you're doing cause either
pretty tough questions it's okay I think
I know my history and I think I'm ready
to go so all right president last is
grandpa let's do this I just don't want
to make a mistake all right here we go
all right here we go
all right are you ready here comes
question number one good what is the
political party of our current president
democratic what is one right or freedom
contained in the First Amendment freedom
of speech what does USA stand for
United States awesome what is the most
American pie apple pie what is the least
American Pie communism pie
what popular condiment can you
mispronounce so it sounds like an insult
must hard what should you do if you're
happy and you know it clap your hands
what should you do if you're unhappy and
you don't know it drink before noon when
you hold the door open for someone and
they don't say thank you what should you
say you're welcome
if the TV shows Cupcake Wars and Whale
Wars were combined into one show what
would it be called Ohio did you see The
Avengers yes what is the most amazing
special effect in the Avengers Scarlett
Johansson's but in the upcoming movie
prometheus what is the earliest ferrin's
but who's the black private dick that's
a sex machine to all the chicks shaft
you're damn right but you see this cat
shaft is a bad mother got your mouth
what I'm talking about chat we can dig
it okay but now I'm going to say a
series of names and you have to tell me
if it's a type of cheese or the name of
a character from Game of Thrones
here we go Asiago cheese Gruyere cheese
Targaryen Game of Thrones Roquefort
cheese Lannister Game of Thrones
camembert to Westeros both describe the
roll impressment played during the War
of 1812 during the War of 1812 Britain
did not recognize the right of a British
man to relinquish his status as a
British subject in the world Navy went
after British born sailors by
intercepting and searching US merchant
ships for deserters which led to
impressment actions such as the leander
affair which outraged Americans because
it infringed on national sovereignty
tonight Americans ability to naturalize
foreigners and because British frigates
with search ships for contraband
impressed men and u.s. territorial
waters making free trade in sailor's
rights rallying cry if united states
rather conflict
all right final question in the upcoming
Dark Knight Rises pathways but
[Applause]